in 2006 two years before the Marvel
Cinematic Universe turned superheroes
into the biggest thing in Hollywood Tim
Kring and future Marvel TV guru Jeph
Loeb introduced the world to heroes
a high concept science fiction series
built around a modern superhero
mythology heroes ran for four wildly
uneven seasons before returning in 2015
with the 13 episode epilogue bureaus
reborn so what else has the cast of
Heroes been up to since the series ended
and how has time treated your favorite
stars here's a look at what the cast of
Heroes looks like today milo ventimiglia
prior to his breakout role as Peter
Petrelli on heroes Milo Ventimiglia was
known as the irascible and romantic Jess
on Gilmore Girls
through every action-packed moment on
heroes Ventimiglia never failed to find
the aching Humanity in his character and
was often the heart that held the series
together these days Ventimiglia is still
providing the heart and soul on a major
TV smash hit as Jack Pearson in the
beloved NBC drama this is us from
Gilmore Girls two heroes - this is us
Ventimiglia is already a TV legend and
he's only in his 40s keep on rockin milo
hayden Panettiere the catchphrase saved
the cheerleader save the world helped
turn heroes into a hit and hayden
Panettiere is one of the hottest few
stars in Hollywood as cheerleader Claire
Bennet Panettiere was at the center of
the series right from the show's opening
moment though Panettiere didn't appear
in heroes reborn she's still been plenty
busy over the past decade besides having
a daughter with her partner heavyweight
champion Wladimir Klitschko she's also
appeared in films like I love you Beth
Cooper and scream 4 but she's best known
these days for her starring role as
Juliette Barnes on Nashville which
earned her two Golden Globe nominations
over the show's six hit seasons
Zachary Quinto brain collecting
Psychopaths Sylar was the terror at the
rotten core of heroes hunting down and
killing some of our
favorite characters not to mention his
own mom but there was a plus side as
Sylar also introduced the world to the
talents of Zachary Quinto since then
Quinto has become a power behind the
scenes as well as in front of the camera
producing films like margin call and TV
shows such as the chair while helping
relaunch Star Trek for a new generation
as the iconic mr. Spock Masi oka prior
to taking on the role of the
time-traveling salaryman Hiro Nakamura
Masi oka was best known for a small role
on scrubs
but as heroes breakout fan favorite hero
oka rocketed to fame earning a Golden
Globe nomination in the process and he
hasn't slowed down either besides making
a cameo in heroes reborn oka earned a
legion of new fans thanks to his
seven-year run as fan favorite max on
Hawaii five-o we can't wait to see what
he's going to do next
[Music]
Greg Grunberg fans of JJ Abrams series
Felicity and alias would be quick to
tell you all about the heartfelt common
man sincerity of actor Greg Grunberg
who played telepathic detective Matt
Parkman on heroes and shockingly turned
to the dark side as a bad guy in heroes
reborn outside of Heroes grünberg has
been keeping active by appearing in
pretty much every project Abrams has
ever done most notably as pilot snap
Wexley in Star Wars The Force awakens
and in 2014 he completed a multi-episode
stint on Showtime's hit series masters
of sex we're still waiting for Grunberg
to get the leading man role he deserves
but we get it
playing JJ's personal mascot has to take
up a lot of his time Jack Coleman his
name is Jack Coleman but the heroes fans
will always be the man in the
horn-rimmed glasses
aka hrg or noah bennet if you're being
really formal a morally grey agent who
specializes in hunting down people with
powers Noah's motives are always kept
close to the vest except when his
daughter Claire is involved in which
case HRG always makes it clear that
family comes first
beyond heroes Coleman has spent the last
decade appearing in numerous guest roles
on TV shows from the office to Castle
we're not sure where he's going to turn
up next but one thing is certain you
haven't seen the last of Jack Coleman
just yet Ali Larter she broke into
Hollywood with a bang thanks to her now
iconic whipped cream bikini scene and
varsity blues and scored raves opposite
Reese Witherspoon in Legally Blonde but
Ali larders career never quite took off
the way fans expected with the notable
exception of her star turn as Niki
Sanders and Nicki's various
doppelgangers and split personalities on
heroes
since heroes went off the air Larter has
starred in TV shows such as legends and
has gained a new generation of fans
thanks to the Resident Evil franchise
now that's the real cherry on top
Cyndi ramamurthy genetics professor
Mohinder Suresh is one of the care
there's that kept bureaus functioning
narrating the action while also
providing all the pseudo scientific
exposition necessary and what now wait a
few seconds see if the enzymes attached
to the core saw so what has Stars
Sendhil Ramamurthy been up to recently
besides reprising his role as dr. Suresh
in heroes reborn Rama Murthy has also
had major roles in shows such as covert
affairs & reverie and from the looks of
it his real superpower is apparently
never aging thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
YouTube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]